hi everyone my name is Sam almond and
this is how to build the future today
our guest is Jessica Livingston the
founder of Y Combinator where I'm at
work
Y Combinator has funded 1,500 startups
and they are worth more than seventy
billion dollars in total more than 10 of
them are worth a billion dollars or more
so in terms of how to create a unicorn
Jessica Livingston probably knows more
about this than maybe anybody else in
the world so we are super delighted you
came here today to talk to us thank you
for having me
what I really want to get out of you is
how founders get on a path to build a
huge company so you have now for 11
years seen founders come in one of just
two or three people and an idea and
sometimes those founders go on to do
nothing most of the time sometimes they
create a small success and sometimes
they create these companies that really
transform the world and NYC has been
very fortunate to be involved in a lot
of those Airbnb Dropbox stripe the list
goes on and what I think would be really
helpful is to talk about what the
companies do during Y Combinator that
allows them to then go on and build
these super impactful companies so what
have you observed the very best
companies do when they're brand new well
I've now seen more than a thousand
companies go through I see so I'm very
familiar what these companies do during
YC and I'm first going to say that
there's not really one path for everyone
necessarily and a lot of times these
successful startups get started almost
accidentally but when they're at the
point where they say yes I am gonna take
this company seriously I'm going to
apply to Y Combinator and then they they
come here to Silicon Valley for three
months the most successful founders I've
noticed are totally focused on two
things building their product and making
something people want which of course is
our motto and talking to their users and
they do not let themselves get
distracted by anything else and that
seems so obvious but what's not obvious
is how easily distracted founders can be
by lots of other things go
and the most successful startups are
like hyper focused on their product what
are some of the things that distract
founders that seem like good ideas at
the time oh um there's a lot of these
and in fact in a talk that I gave it the
female founders conference a couple
months ago I referred to some of these
things as like the startup equivalent of
wolves in sheep's clothing because they
really do seem like you're doing
business a few of them are talking to
big companies to try to form
partnerships in an attempt to get better
distribution or somehow you know get
more users to do a lot of PR before
you've nailed down the product to talk
to Corp dev people when you're not
thinking about being acquired yet you'll
still have meetings with these people or
you'll take meetings with investors when
you're not in fundraising mode just to
sort of build a relationship I mean
those or go to going to conferences
networking events all these things that
seem like important things to do as part
of your business are not important in
the very early stages when it's critical
to build your product how do you know
when you have hit the product as you
just said well I think when you have
people using it like you can measure
your growth and you can measure how many
users you get and are they coming back
are they paying for your product I mean
that's just the greatest thing of all if
you can charge for your product and and
that that growth rate is still so for
all the YC companies that have gone on
to be these sort of household names did
they all do this during YC where they
just focused on their growth rate
writing code talking to users and if
they the companies ended up ignoring
everything else uh yeah pretty much if I
had to think back on the most successful
startups all during YC they were super
focused and they weren't all over the
place in terms of ideas that they were
working on or things that they were
doing they were definitely focused did
they have big plans even during YC like
could Brian Chesky of Airbnb have told
you during YC
here's how we're gonna be a twenty five
billion dollar company and here's we're
gonna look like seven years later I
don't think they would have gone that
far I think that all of the most
successful founders have ambitious plans
and they certainly start a lot smaller
like they seem much less important when
they're first getting started but I
think the founders do have a grand plan
I have to believe though that when
they're all in the earliest phases none
of them can predict just how big they'll
be I don't think Brian Chesky knew that
they'd be where they are today and how
much strategizing do you think the
companies do about how they're going to
get from here to the next step for the
step after that like during YC are they
really just focused on trying to make a
few users really happy or are they
thinking about well we need to build up
a monopoly and so an Airbnb 'z case will
have that because we'll have one
marketplace or is it really just like
let's build this product people love and
see where it goes
I really do think it starts as let's
build this product and see where it goes
in some cases let's solve our own
problem and see where it goes I'm
specifically thinking of stripe I mean
they built that product because it was a
pain in the ass for themselves they were
solving something for themselves so I do
think that they are saying let's build
this and see where it goes however I
think that the most successful ones do
have that grander vision I remember
specifically during YC air B&B said to
themselves and and I think to investors
we plan to become the eBay of space like
they were nowhere near the eBay of space
at that point but they had that vision
and they were working toward that how
much does the idea matter like you said
Airbnb
came with this idea that turned out to
actually be the eBay of space um but a
lot of founders I think don't get
started because they don't yet feel like
they have the idea that can be the
hundred billion dollar company so how
important do you think it is to get the
idea just right at the beginning or to
just get started with something and then
figure out where to take it I'm of the
mind of just get started with something
and
that's because we are funding companies
at such an early stage that we're really
funding the companies for the founders
and for the attributes of the founders
do they seem determined have they been
able to ship something in the past do
they seem you know open-minded about
things are they domain experts a lot of
times they don't get the idea right the
very first time they might be in the
general vicinity of being right but then
they have to adjust their idea some
founders totally fail with their I
didn't have to have to change completely
but I think it's more important to get
started with something build it because
your idea is always gonna evolve
I mean Airbnb is like to me one of the
most famous examples of an idea that has
evolved right right
they came to us with their idea which
was at the time renting out air beds in
your home while you were there during
conferences like that's pretty focused
right and then they they said okay now
we're gonna rent out air beds in your
home but not during conferences then it
was renting out your own home so it
morph and did all of that morphing
happened during the YC program no it did
not happen specifically to take um I
think it should I want to say it took
about a year um I'm not a hundred
percent certain but I remember what
happened specifically was Airbnb was
always very strict about the host being
home so that they could provide
breakfast right because it was a bed and
breakfast stomachs um and then the
famous story is that air or Airbnb is
one of their hosts was Barry Manilow's
drummer and he had this great place in
New York City and he contacted them and
said hey Barry's going on tour I'm gonna
be gone
can I just rent out my my apartment
while I'm not there I like the Airbnb
Zrii like oh that doesn't really fit
well that's how they figured up that's
how we figured out how to like rent out
whole spaces and to this day I think
that that's like the majority of their
business but it took something like that
to get them to even consider
are doing it could you tell the story of
what you thought the first time you met
the Airbnb founders when they came in to
interview for YC I mean I know they were
in kind of a rough place they were
totally out of money every investor had
said no to them yes we actually do not
know what a rough place they were in I
know that now from hearing stories but
they this was 2009 right this was
actually in the fall of 2008 well we did
the interviews in November and for
people that weren't around in fall of
2008 it was really a grim time to be
doing a start-up in Silicon Valley
because the macroeconomic conditions had
collapsed so macroeconomic conditions
had collapsed no one knew what was gonna
happen
right angels were you know closing their
checkbooks people oh we're gonna hold
off on investing it was really sort of a
scary time and so I room I do remember
we went into interview saying we're only
gonna choose companies that we think
could make it to profitability really
quickly on their own and then they can
like live as a cockroach because you
just weren't sure they'd be able to
raise any money at all right we weren't
sure that they that come March at demo
day that we had no idea what what
investors would be doing and so we were
really sort of frightened it would be a
disaster if we had this big demo day and
none of the startups could get more
funding that would be bad so we were
very strict so the Airbnb --zz came in
they were sort of a last minute addition
to the the interview process I remember
Michael Seibel one of the partners here
said hey can you slot these guys in
they're really good
least come have them come in so we said
fine and I remember during the interview
Paul tried to change their idea we
thought this idea of like renting out
air beds was a little weird um what did
he try to change it to I don't even
remember it's embarrassing well good
thing he didn't I know I know he but he
did try to like pitch them a new idea
and they're like no no um and and that's
just one of those things they knew they
were onto something because they
themselves were hosts and that is one of
the key things
um about founders is that like when when
you're using your own product or solving
your own
you have all this like these insights
that no one else has and the Airbnb ease
we're renting out their their room in
their apartment because they couldn't
pay their own rent so they had a lot of
insights into sort of funny given the
current controversy on Airbnb that
Airbnb started as an affordable housing
company I you know it's it's outrageous
so um they were using they were using
their own product they had these
insights that it was this wonderful
experience when someone comes out of
town to have hosts that can help them
and show them around and and they they
knew they were on to something
so they convinced us that their idea had
legs and that their users you know the
few users they had loved them I remember
more about the founders though I really
like the founders they were very
convincing when they spoke you could
tell they had thought about this problem
a lot they didn't have all the answers
by any means but they just seemed like
they had thought about this a lot and I
remember also they brought in as a gift
the cereal boxes Obama ohms and cap cap
and McCain's or something and the 2008
presidential election 2008 presidential
election and they had made these cereal
boxes with like Cheerios and Captain
Crunch in them and which sounds so silly
because their cereal but I remember they
said oh yeah you know we designed these
and then we went out and got Cheerios
and we stuffed him in there and glue gun
the boxes together and we've been giving
them away and I thought oh my god these
guys are like glue gunning the cereal
box they why were they doing this um
they really were doing this because they
were out of money and this is like a
Hail Mary for them and they they did
wind up making a lot of money from these
but to us they were doing it as sort of
a fun thing because their Airbnb they
provide breakfast coincided with the
presidential elections but the original
driving reason was just like they
couldn't raise any money they couldn't
raise any money anything they could to
survive oh my god when you we
again during the interview we did not
know these stories but when you hear the
stories of the problems that they had
trying to fundraise prior to YC it's
crazy
they had one investor like leave in the
middle of a pitch just walk out without
even saying good goodbye no one believed
this idea was good or certainly would be
big did you know at the time that the
idea could be great or was it for you
really just a bet on those three guys as
founders I have to admit it was more of
a bet on the three founders they seemed
really good I did sort of like the idea
of of being able to stay in people's
homes but I have to admit I was I was
not thinking it was gonna be huge just
because that story was so interesting
what was it like when you met the
Carlson brothers I think they were 19
and 17 when they started stripe and they
came in and said we're gonna do this
crazy thing and we're teenagers and
we're going to take on the financial
system of the world how does that
conversation go well I have to admit we
met Patrick years earlier when he was 16
or 17 still living in Ireland because he
looked up Paul and we had him over for
dinner so it wasn't like we first met
them at a YC interview um we we I think
Patrick was working on some other idea
first or something and we had you know
high regard for him he certainly was
good at building things and he had like
a Wikipedia app so we knew he was like a
talented programmer he introduced us to
his 16 year old brother 16 there we go
he was 16 when we met him John was um
and I'm trying to remember when they
said oh we're gonna take on the
financial industry I think we were kind
of like do you realize how hard this is
and like you don't have connections um
but they were intrepid they're like well
we don't have connections we'll find
connections and they just thought that
is actually a really good question that
you bring up because it shows how
determined they were and how focused
they were and I mean you think like the
head of a bank is going to take a
nineteen-year
old startup founder seriously it seems
pretty implausible right but they were
good enough that they were able to
convince these banks to work with them
are there other traits in in the
founders that go on to really change
change the future the size determination
that separate the very best founders
from the mediocre founders have you have
you noticed any other traits that kind
of founders should aspire to that really
want to have a big impact yes um if I
had to say the most important traits of
the most successful founders I've
already mentioned determination that is
by far the most important more than
intelligence more than intelligence more
than previous success you know in school
I mean remember when we started Y
Combinator our hypothesis was Oh we'll
just fund all the best hackers from MIT
and Harvard and they'll turn out to be
great startup founders that is not true
that is absolutely not true a lot of
them are good and in fact Patrick was
from MIT but it's it's not true for the
most part determination is the most
important thing again sort of
understanding your users and building a
product with a great user experience is
second most important not being
distracted not getting lured down these
paths that aren't going to be important
for building building your your product
being flexible minded I've always felt
is very important because you have this
idea and you test it out and it doesn't
always work the first time and so you
have to be able to say okay I thought I
was going to do this but let's try this
even though I have like a lot of energy
vested in this let's try this direction
you really have to be open-minded and
then ultimately you have to be a good
leader you have to be convincing and a
good leader because you are going to be
convincing employees to join you you're
going to beacon
investors to invest in you when you do
get to the point where you're doing
deals with bigger companies you have to
convince them like your whole world is
convincing people and so you have to be
able to communicate your idea and and
convince people why they should care
about you more than any of the other
hundreds of startups out there so now
I'd like to talk about your startup Y
Combinator and and how you started that
could you tell us the story of starting
Y Combinator yeah it was it was very
much started in the same way that a
startup is started where Paul and I had
this idea we really felt that that the
investment world was broken if you were
an early-stage startup and you just
wanted to like test something out you
either had to go to VC and get five
million dollars which is virtually
impossible at that early stage or you
had to know someone who was rich and
could give you money and we thought
there could be something better we
thought there could be like a
standardized branded form of funding so
if you wanted $25,000 or whatever you
could come to Y Combinator and we'd make
it very easy for you so we thought okay
let's start an investment company and it
was just gonna be Paul and me and then
we sort of lured in his old co-founders
Robert Morris and Trevor Blackwell to be
part of this even though they were
full-time on something else and we said
gosh none of us know anything about
angel investing well let's learn so how
should we do that let's fund a whole
bunch of companies at once and learn a
lot so we set up a website and we said
come join the summer founders program it
was back in Cambridge Massachusetts in
it was for the summer of 2005 and we
started working on it let's just say in
January and and we posted an application
we wanted to change a few specific
things we wanted to make it very easy
for people to find us and apply they
didn't have to have a connection to us
we had an application of like 20
questions we wanted to make it very
simple on our side
we're giving you $12,000 you know per
startup or eighteen thousand if you had
three founders but it was very specific
amount for this amount of stock and our
paperwork is going to be real
straightforward you can see it in
advance and we're going to make the
decision that day we'll interview you
and tell you that night and that never
happened back before us no one got a
same-day decision for the most part so
200 people applied they had known about
Paul because of his essays you were one
of them it was came out from Stanford I
remember that interview very well and we
found eight companies to fund that
summer and we learned very very quickly
into the three months that funding
startups in a batch was incredibly
powerful and it was powerful in that you
could teach them all sort of the same
things at once and they became
colleagues because starting a start-up
as one or two people is very lonely and
very isolating and back then in 2005
there was no information online about
early-stage startups at all so no one
knew what they were doing so it was sort
of a nice atmosphere so even why coming
it was an example of this start with an
idea you don't know much about build
something people want and iterate yes
yes yes yes
we started with my light and start small
do it lightweight start small and evolve
and we realized we had dinners on
Tuesday nights which actually we still
have to this day and we have guest
speakers come in we had paperwork that
we gave them I personally helped
everyone incorporate their company um
what else did you spend your time on
that first summer oh my god what didn't
I spend my time on like as any startup
there was like too much for everyone to
do Paul spent his time advising the
startups on their ideas because I didn't
really know that much about startups I
was doing everything to get Y Combinator
up and running I mean we had to get in
our office we had to cook dinners I was
growing grocery shopping and Paul was
cooking the dinner
um we were recruiting speakers to speak
that summer this is now most people
picture doing when they think about
starting a really important company I
think it's good to note this isn't my
god there's so much unglamorous work
that founders have to do early on and
you just have to do it um but I'm I was
delivering air conditioners to different
people um we had eight startups in that
batch and they were all living scattered
around the Harvard Square area and there
was a heat wave and we were like we
can't have our founders not being able
to work so I went to Home Depot and I
bought like ten air conditioners and
delivered them to everyone why don't you
know that summer the Y Combinator was
going to work um we had a feeling pretty
early on like first couple of weeks I
would say within the first month we're
like this is really interesting and
people are working on very interesting
ideas I mean you were working on
location stuff on your phone it wasn't
like reddit was in there we're very
interested in reddit um the justin.tv
and twitch guys just inanimate we're
working on a calendar unfortunately
Google Calendar launched and that's
killed them yeah I mean matter these are
these were interesting things um and so
we were very excited about the ideas
it's a great story about investing in
people that it was Justin's third Y
Combinator startup I think that ended up
being a billion dollar exit yeah yeah
and I see one him three times and it
worked out on a third and it worked out
the third time's a charm
yes I mean this is again going back to
your funding the people just inanimate
we're a great team
um I'll just this is a bit of a tangent
but it's important to remember they were
college roommates and like best friends
or growing up and so they had known each
other for a long time and had this like
great trust and so when they wanted to
build something they were both excellent
programmers you know and that's as good
of a bet as you can make that ultimately
here is it that Co found to have
co-founders at all and then how
important is it that the co-founders
have a pre-existing relationship like
that I think it's critical um I think I
think there have been cases of
successful startups with one
founder but I'm sure they will tell you
it's extremely hard and overwhelming
emotionally draining
you have no peer who you can rely on for
moral support and and holding all of
that you know it's a big burden for
people emotionally I think also at the
very early stages there's so much to get
done that you need more than one person
doing it you know you can't be out
fundraising and building the product at
the same time so yes it's important to
have a co-founder it's not impossible um
I will say it's critical that you know
your co-founder well um because if you
don't if you like me at a hackathon and
think you ever see that work out rarely
I'm trying to think of an example and
off the top of my head I can't think of
an example Wow um of two people who were
introduced or sort of bolted on to each
other at the last minute ever working
I'm sure there are examples of it has
having that work but I can't think of
them um the the relationship becomes so
stressed as a start-up goes on its path
I mean you have like in Port you could
get sued and you have to deal with this
or you get an acquisition offer that's
really tempting and that can cause
friction you know so many things can
cause friction and tension it's really
like a marriage and I know we all laugh
at how we compare founder relationships
to a marriage but in many ways it's kind
of there's a lot of truth to that yeah
yeah so you said about within the first
month you don't know why she was on to
something but when did you first realize
that why she was going to be as vague as
it has turned out to be did you have any
idea of that that summer I don't think
we had any idea of that that summer we
knew we were onto something and and
after that summer we knew we had to come
out to Silicon Valley that was an
important next decision for us we knew
that people could easily copy us and we
didn't want someone else to be the Y
Combinator of Silicon Valley like we
wanted to be the Y Combinator of Silicon
Valley
and I remember Paul saying we got to go
out there and I remember thinking like
ah we have two months to do this
was that really driven by not wanting to
be copied uh yeah
well we did not want someone else to be
the Y Combinator Silicon Valley notice
that was great startups a lot that they
really don't they really hate their they
really hate getting copied I think
that's an interesting point well you
know I think no one likes getting copied
just um it's it's unpleasant I'm used to
it by now
um and you just can't worry about it
your oh if you are building something
great you're gonna get copied um so
anyway so we came out here and that was
also very important for us because we
didn't have relationships in Silicon
Valley we didn't know the investors out
here and that's when we started to meet
the investors and that's an incredibly
important component of Y Combinator that
we have you know great relationships
with investors and they they come to our
demo days and they invest in our
startups because again we are like first
gear for startups we're helping them get
started and then we want to introduce
them to like wonderful later stage
investors so once you you got to Silicon
Valley and started running the program
out here then did you know it was gonna
be really bad not yet not yet I think I
think when we had a feeling that it was
gonna be really good was when I you know
reddit got bought and that was very
exciting news for us but I think like
when Dropbox started getting some
traction then we thought like whoa this
could be a contender here this is you
know someone doing really really well
and you were funded and our sort of
companies were sort of flourishing and
that that's when we knew I think I think
this could be and what does it like
looking back now and you know what why
commenter has become this this pretty
influential thing that has impacted a
lot of people in a lot of industries
like looking back is there anything
you're like well if I knew YC was going
to be as important as it's become I
would have done this differently or
anything that any lessons that you take
away or is it just like well this
happened and I was only ever looking one
step ahead in time you know
there's always things that you do a
little bit differently
possibly we would have hired more
partners earlier on so that we could
have accomplished more I mean for many
years it was just Paul and me full time
and so there was only so much we could
do so we didn't do much outreach and we
you know I wish maybe we could have done
more of that earlier on um
but you know in the grand scheme of
things there's not there's no like
massive massive mistake I think we sort
of grew organically and what is it that
you did as you were growing organically
that has made YC works so well you know
a recent someone recently told me
they're not 2,500 accelerators around
the world Oh God however all every
billion plus dollar companies so far
ever to come out mix alright I think
there's 11 have have happened in part of
YC so that's a you know a great credit
to you and Paul but what did you do in
the early days that set up YC to to do
this well there were a couple things and
you know sometimes I would be nervous
about sharing some of our secret weapons
but I'm going to share one because it
would be great if people copied this but
they won't one of the most important
things is that is that Y Combinator
always started to be founder friendly we
were not doing this to make money
um we were doing this to see if we could
encourage more startups to get started
because we felt that would be good for
the world like more people starting
startups more innovation that's good for
the world and so we didn't do it
thinking we could make money and we
weren't trying to like squeeze out the
best deals in every situation we were
always driven by what's best for the
founders what's best for the startups
are terms in our investment paperwork
are very founder friendly and I think
that's attracted um good founders who
want to be treated fairly and not to be
taken advantage of
um it's interesting you see that among
many of Y C's most successful founders
they're they want to make a lot of money
but that is far from the primary mission
yes you cannot
be the most successful startup founder
if you were driven by money you have to
be driven by a greater purpose
so why cease version of this was just
like it'd be good for the world to treat
founders better and have a lot more
startups yes yes now we hoped we made
some money because we couldn't keep self
funding for the rest of our lives we
couldn't be self-sustaining if we didn't
make some money and by the way for many
years we didn't hate conning it takes I
remember that people forget that people
forget yeah how long it takes to make
money as an investor um so we were
always driven by like this benevolence
um and I think it's still part of our
DNA I truly believe that um I think we
gave great advice um you know
surprisingly hard to get from investors
yes yes there are some great investors
out there that do give great advice but
for the most part getting really good
advice it's hard I think Paul Graham's
exceptional at giving start-up advice
and helping people with their ideas um
and quite honestly um telling people
like hey you're doing this you're doing
wrong don't do it that way in a way
that's very straightforward young and
and and founders can respond to that
pretty quickly
um what else what are you know what are
the important things about us I mean
we've always had attracted from the very
first batch that you were in I believe
we attracted you know talented founders
and they've gone on to be role models
and attract other people that are
talented like kind intelligent founders
and so I think it's just sort of grown
organically and and spread and we've
kept a pretty pretty great community of
founders over the years so there are a
lot of people that have realized
startups are really great ways to impact
the world and get new technology built
and distributed and at a young age now
people are realizing they may want to
start a start-up someday so if you're an
ambitious you know teenager or college
student
what should you spend your time line if
you know someday you want to start a
startup well there's a lot of things you
can
do to prepare yourself to be a start-up
founder the first is learn to code
there's a lot of great online courses
now if you don't already know how to
code but I would strongly recommend that
everyone learn to code even if you're
not great you at least know how to do it
and it helps you sort of judge other
programmers build stuff with people it
doesn't have to be like the next
Facebook which by the way did start out
obviously as a little side project um
when it got started but just build
something that you might like to use try
to solve your own problem work with
other people I mean especially if you're
in college that is just the best place
to meet potential co-founders um and get
to know people and talk about
interesting problems and try to solve
them it does not have to be the next
startup but it will at least get you
thinking about problems it will get you
like practicing launching something and
listening to users and talking to users
and after that if you're not ready to
start a start-up right away go work at
an early stage startup you can learn so
much working at an early stage startup
that you wouldn't working at a big
company so that's probably my best
advice of what to do to prep to become a
start-up founder great ok last question
yeah um you are probably the most
successful female founder in Silicon
Valley at this point so do you have
advice for other female founders or
aspiring female founders about what to
do well it's definitely a subject I
think about a lot because when we first
started Y Combinator there were very few
female founders they were scarce and I'm
pleased that there are more these days
and they're just continuing to be more
and so I've spent a lot of time trying
to help the women that we've funded to
become more successful so that they can
go on to inspire people because you have
to have those role models so that you
can think gosh maybe I could start a
startup
but I will give some advice based on my
own experience you can't worry too much
about what everyone's saying and all the
noise and like oh it's so much harder as
a woman
yes it's harder as a woman I've been
discriminated against
you know it's but I have always kept
focused on my product and you know what
I'm doing and I don't listen to all this
stuff going on and I'm like building a
product that people love and I think
that the women we funded would say the
same thing their startup founders you
know they're not like necessarily like
female startup founders there are first
and foremost startup founders and they
are caring about their product and their
users and they are totally focused on
that and so my advice is like just do it
start a company apply the Y Combinator
um and and you know build something
people want great well thank you so much
for joining us and funding my company
and hiring me that's great thanks a lot
I think Sam